to say we've got this new word called
well-being of well-being so now we have
to look after you all but but we can do
examples like that saying
that without it taking you with it like
this okay so you don't want it to take
your spirit and your body you just want
to be able to do the thrust so the the
next one so we're here the next one is
here
cut step
forward
thrust
cut
thrust look don't worry about it cuz you
know there's a lot of difference between
me and yourselves
but try to remember that you you you
want to check yourself oh I'm
leaning you know you always got a mirror
or a window or something at
home yeah I'm
okay yeah I'm okay you know you can just
quickly check that and the quicker you
can get into not leaning but getting
maximum the
quicker you'll Advance without carrying
all this garbage that you got under
uh you might have had other teachers say
give me a like my teacher over there
give me a white piece of paper rather
than one what's been written on s s
sense he used to say stop him if he does
a Thousand Cuts like that however long
is it going to take me to get him to do
the right ones so he used to like to get
you uh doing the the right stuff okay so
so we're going to do the seventh suburi
so into the second suburi we cut with
the right foot forward we then step with
the left and we push we cut and step
with the right and we push with the left
we step with the right and we push with
the left keep going